Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
conversamos Con Juanita Vélez ella es
periodista y politóloga colombiana y ha
venido aquí a conversar con nosotros es
también cofundadora de la fundación
conflicto hisponcis Muchas gracias
Juanita por estar en la entrevista de
France 24 no muchas gracias a ustedes
por la invitación acaba de publicar una
guerra después con editorial Aguilar
sigue la historia de seis personas dos
guerrilleros un funcionario un militar
un policía una de sus objetivos del
libro era responder Qué países Colombia
Cuál es su respuesta después de escribir
una guerra después Bueno yo creo que
Colombia son varios países o sea Creo
que condensamos muchas realidades muy
distintas y que la imposibilidad de que
esos países hablen y se entiendan mejor
es lo que ha explicado también en buena
parte del conflicto armado Y esa es mi
respuesta yo creo que hay muchos países
interactuando y el libro Nos invita a
conocerlos esos países Usted cree
después de toda la reportería que empezó
en 2016 empezó a escribir después en
2020 Usted cree que después de todo este
tiempo ahora el país sí que estaría más
preparado para responder a ese
plebiscito
Yo creo que el país sigue o sea estas
emociones que dejan el plebiscito la
polarización está división se mantiene y
se ha acentuado bastante y creo que no
esperaría un resultado muy diferente hoy
frente al de 2016 creo que esta división
se mantiene entre quienes están con una
salida negociada y quiénes no y pues
parte del reto hacia adelante es ver
cómo se puede compensar eso pero por
ahora yo diría que casi que se daría el
mismo resultado uno de los miedos que se
ven en el libro de parte de las FARC que
es que se les veía como derrotados sin
embargo más allá de la dejación de armas
una derrota que sí que parece que se
siente en el libro es la fragmentación
interna que hubo sí digamos Hay una
fragmentación que viene desde antes de
que ellos dejen las armas y que va a
pesar de forma grave después en la
conformación del partido eso está
contado con bastante detalle yo que el
reto que el partido comunes tiene para
sobrevivir porque ellos tienen su
personería jurídica hasta el 2026 es
precisamente superar esas divisiones y
ellos quieren sobrevivir como fuerza
política Entonces si este estás como una
división que viene que viene desde hace
muchísimos años y que el debate de dejar
las armas y Meterse a los votos les
significó ver esas divisiones y pues
enfrentarlas y pues lo que vemos es que
les ha Pesado en su en su en su
conformación como partido pero creo que
hacia futuro podrían tratar de
resolverlo respecto a estas divisiones
hay un fragmento que me llamó la
atención que es mientras los del
secretariado como Márquez o catatumbo
celebraban al son de la Trova que le
canta la revolución los rasos oían
música norteña habían dos FARC
completamente distintas sí es decir yo
creo que las FARC tenían pues Una
fragmentación entre el secretariado el
mismo secretariado en el mismo
secretariado había divisiones estos
mandos medios
quienes tenían digamos una plata en el
bolsillo
Pese a que las FARC no habían sueldos
pero pues de alguna manera tenían unos
una plata las expectativas que ellos
iban a tener a futuro Pues eran
distintas Y eso lo ven no solo las
mismas FARC que pues como usted lo dice
estaban fragmentadas sino también
funcionarios del estado que empiezan a
decir esto es una pirámide que está
dividida que está fragmentada cómo vamos
a hacer para ofrecerles cosas distintas
en su paso a la legalidad porque acá las
expectativas Son son diferentes el
secretariado yo creo que sí soñaba más
con el partido pero lo que uno veía es
que pues estos mandos medios tal vez
querían pues o seguir con una vida más
campesina en las regiones y No
necesariamente en el congreso Entonces
cómo hacer para que ese paso a la vida
civil tuvieran cuenta todas esas
distintas expectativas creo que eso
también está en el libro escrito y
reseñado ya habla también de la
diferencia entre que venían más de esa
fundación de las FARC originales y en lo
que se terminó convirtiendo
sí de acuerdo hay unos
excomandantes y ex guerrilleros que si
vienen como esa semilla y otros que pues
ya llegan más adelante y creo que al
final algo que yo descubrí haciendo este
libro es que pese a que las FARC eran un
proyecto Nacional de toma de poder y
llegaron a hacer la guerrilla más grande
de Colombia su cohesión no era tan
grande como como creíamos cuando uno
empieza a reportear y a entender mejor
cómo funcionaban pues las FARC no eran
tan cohesionadas eso lo dicen ellos
mismos Ellos dicen nosotros éramos unas
en chocó otros en los Llanos otros en
arauca y para que nuestro proyecto
encarnara en cada región tenía que pues
tener en cuenta esas particularidades
regionales y yo creo que entender eso es
clave entender que las para que lograron
ser un proyecto nacional Pero tenían una
un tema o pues una difícil cohesión es
importante y es fundamental para
entender la situación del partido hoy
uno de los aspectos que también se
siente en el libro es alrededor de la
tentación que fue para muchos que luego
terminaron en las disidencias alrededor
del narcotráfico faltó también en el
acuerdo un mayor énfasis en ver esas
cabezas del narcotráfico también para
haber evitado desde un principio esas
disidencias Sí yo creo yo creo que lo
que faltó fue pensar en ofertas
distintas para las distintas como
decíamos ahorita partes de esa pirámide
Porque inevitablemente en cualquier
proceso de paz en el mundo siempre hay
disidencias o sea siempre hay un una
población que termina No dejando las
armas eso es normal pero creo que si se
pudieran se pudieron haber hecho
esfuerzos para tratar de evitar que pues
estas personas tuvieran ese incentivo Y
eso se hubiera podido evitar con una
oferta de pronto distinta
teniendo en cuenta los perfiles de cada
uno de los miembros de la guerrilla y
pues ya había unas cosas que no se iban
a poder hablar por el modelo mismo de la
negociación Pues que era discutir el
modelo económico o discutir la doctrina
militar que eran como líneas rojas del
gobierno y que algunas de las hoy
disidencias querían que eso se
discutiera eso ya es otro plano y va a
ser más difícil pero yo estoy convencida
de que si se piensa una oferta la
legalidad diferenciada según los
perfiles tal vez No tendríamos tantos
disidentes como los que tenemos esos
disidentes por ejemplo son Iván mordisco
o Iván Márquez ahora el gobierno está en
conversaciones con ambos por qué ahora
sí que aceptarían un acuerdo de paz Yo
creo que ellos sienten una alineación o
en un momento clave de sentarse y es que
ha llegado Un gobierno de izquierda al
poder y creo que tanto para ellos como
para sus bases sociales no sentarse con
el primer gobierno de izquierda pues es
desperdiciar una oportunidad histórica
en la que yo sienten que pueden alinear
algunos algunos temas creo que eso es
fundamental y creo que hay como un
pedido y una presión cada vez más grande
de sus bases de que de que exista una
paz de verdad de que se negocia una paz
de verdad La pregunta es pues cómo se va
a hacer y ese ese digamos ya es otro
capítulo que yo no quise ni siquiera
meterme en el libro porque creo que
ameritaría otro libro que es que va a
pasar con la paz total sí Y usted Cómo
la ve después de esta reportería las
conversaciones que ha tenido con
excombatientes con militares con
funcionarios pues me parece que va a ser
un proceso muy complicado Me parece que
el reto de que se tengan distintas mesas
al mismo tiempo va a ser que
inevitablemente lo que pase en una mesa
termina incidiendo en otra creo que acá
también hay un tema pues difícil de
cohesión si las FARC no eran
cohesionadas las disidencias digamos
menos O sea
el Estado Mayor central liderado por
Iván mordisco y la segunda marquetalia
pues no tenemos tan claro Cuál es su
grado de comando y sabemos que se
coordinan pero todavía hay muchas
preguntas sobre la subordinación Y si
eso fue un reto con las Farc Imagínese
cómo va a ser ahora con las disidencias
Entonces yo creo que sentarse con un
grupo que del que tenemos serias
preguntas sobre su cohesión Pero además
entender que el reto o lo que quiere
hacer al gobierno es negociar con varios
grupos al tiempo pues Esto va a implicar
una cosa mayúscula que pues va a ser
difícil lograr además en cuatro años eso
es lo que yo considero una de las
sensaciones también en el libro es que
es reincorporados Pese a que están
felices de haber hecho la paz No todo ha
sido como se esperaban esa sensación de
frustración también puede afectar en una
negociación como con el ejército de
liberación nacional puedan decir mira
cómo les ha ido a ellos Tenemos que
tener cuidado que nos pase lo mismo
total de hecho eso es algo que incluso
el mismo Ln e incluso las mismas
disidencias uno pues ya les Ha oído
decir pues si el estado no le cumplió
Pues a los de las Farc en el acuerdo
2016 y Esto va tan lento nosotros qué
garantías tenemos de que este gobierno
nos vaya nos vaya a cumplir y uno si
siente eso lo que usted acaba de decir
los personajes
Pese a que siguen apostándole al acuerdo
y están convencidos Pues hay cierto
grado de frustración de que hay cambios
que esperaban ver más rápido y no están
ocurriendo entonces Claro que sí claro
que el acuerdo de paz se va a volver un
espejo para los procesos que arranquen y
un espejo sobre el cumplimiento del
Estado entonces por eso yo también
siento que una guerra después se vuelve
fundamental para este momento porque nos
sirve para entender qué pasó con este
proceso de paz que con todos sus
críticas y con todas sus fallas Pues
desarmó a 13.000 personas qué pasó Y eso
De qué nos habla de los procesos que se
quieran hacer adelante también se siente
el miedo que sienten muchos firmantes el
estado ha hecho todo lo posible por
protegerlos
yo creo que hay muchas fallas en como el
estado ha tratado de protegerlos creo
que esto no se trata y ahí por ejemplo
lo dice el mismo pastor a lape miembro
del hoy partido comunes Esto no se trata
de que nos pongan escoltas a todos los
miembros de las FARC y creo que el
problema con su protección también parte
de una un desentendimiento de las
regiones un desentendimiento de lo que
está pasando en las zonas veredales y en
estos campamentos donde algunos de ellos
viven ya La minoría pero algunos creo
que hay un desentendimiento creo que
ellos se desarmaron en un contexto con
otros grupos armados Y eso iba a ser
Inevitable estas amenazas pero también
previsibles o sea el estado sabía esto y
creo que hay unas fallas en la manera
como se han propuesto como los han
protegido ya tenemos más de 350
asesinatos de manera que sí creo que hay
que repensar las estrategias de
seguridad para su protección para
terminar el libro también hace énfasis
en Pues los crímenes que cometieron las
FARC especialmente hablar mucho del
secuestro Cuántas generaciones hará
falta para que ese perdón sea efectivo
pues no tengo una respuesta sobre
Cuántas generaciones creo y pues
invitaría a todos a que vean el
testimonio de una víctima que está en el
libro que es el sargento retirado César
lazo quien pese a estar 13 años
secuestrado por las partes Ya siente que
perdonó el sigue exigiendo justicia pero
pues perdonó y Está tratando de
propiciar encuentros de perdón con los
ex guerrilleros yo siento que el
secuestro es una herida enorme en la
historia de Colombia y me parece que el
trabajo que haga la g el sistema de
verdad y de justicia de aquí en adelante
pues también determinará que tanto vamos
cerrando esa herida Pero al menos ya la
estamos viendo creo que lo que permitió
ese sistema es que veamos la herida
veamos lo onda que es y tratemos de
empezar a sanarlo Ahora sí una última el
gobierno de Gustavo es el primero de
izquierda de la historia de Colombia
Cómo ha cambiado la vida para esos
excombatientes o en esos actos de perdón
desde la llegada al poder de Gustavo
Petro y Francia Márquez Pues si nos
enfocamos en en los ex guerrilleros de
las FARC
la verdad es que Petro les genera como
una sensación ambivalente o sea Ellos
tienen puesta sus apuestas en que con
este gobierno se implemente el acuerdo
han visto que el gobierno tiene una
posición un poco
tenue frente al acuerdo pero ellos
tienen puestas todas sus fichas en que
este gobierno realmente lo implemente
hay otros ex guerrilleros a quienes he
entrevistado Y la verdad sienten que no
va a cambiar en mucho su realidad que
haya llegado él o sea hay como una
mezcla de expectativas frente a su
llegada al poder definitivamente Claro
que saludan que se trata de el primer
gobierno de izquierda y ven una
oportunidad de que ahí de pronto se
canalice lo que ellos esperan pero como
digo hay como una mezcla también hay
otros que simplemente sienten que que no
les va a cambiar en nada su realidad y
vamos a ver qué pasa con esto concluimos
Muchas gracias Juanita por estar en la
entrevista de France 24 no muchas
gracias a ustedes por la invitación y
los invito a leer el libro Pueden seguir
más contenidos como este en francés 24 y
Frank 24.com
[Música]